[Music]
hello everyone thanks for coming and I'm
very happy that you are here mm-hmm
I am a computer science student at
Warsaw University and I will tell you
something about the analogies in word to
vac vector space and first a few
questions
who knows what word avec is oh that's
great
who doesn't know and who's who's heard
of it when didn't raise his hand yeah
okay cool and who's a vector work to vex
specialist and knows everything about
work Tuvok cool that's that's great
nobody okay so basically what avec is
the general idea behind work to work is
the distributional hypothesis and it
basically it can be summed up to a word
is characterized to the company it keeps
by the company it keeps so so what we
mean is that when towards a car in the
same context almost always they probably
have the same meaning but it's a little
bit controversy what we mean by meaning
but I want those into that so we have we
have we have the word a appears in the
context of the word see so like I said
towards have similar meanings if they
appear in the same context with the same
probability okay so that's that's great
we can tell if if towards if the words
have the similar meaning that's that's
cool but but then to do that we would
have to
- no - no the probabilities for each
pair and that's quadratic memory and we
don't like that that would be gigabytes
of space so what we do is we introduce
something like point wise point wise
mutual information which basically tells
us how much are they towards probable to
occur together then if they were
randomly occurring that's how much one
word appearance of one word tells us
about the probability of appearance of
the second word and we want to
approximate this PMI and we do it by
finding finding a vector for each word
those vectors we want to compute the the
PMI for two for two words and what we do
is we take the dot product for of the
two vectors and thus we've got the PMI
we've got to find those vectors and
that's when the worth of echo magic
happens that's that's that's a very deep
topic and I want I want actually those
into how to find those vectors but
rather tell you about what we can do
with those vectors can you hear me yeah
cool okay so so we've got the let's
imagine we find those vectors we found
two vectors that's cool but yet the
vector similarity means that the words
are similar we're not so sure so
so so we want to actually check it so
we've got the equality of the
probabilities for for each pair for
every word and then dividing by the
probably odd probability of what see
appearing and taking the logarithm we've
got the Equality of of the p.m. eyes we
approximated the p.m. I spy by the
vectors vector dot product and now
taking to the other side we so if it has
to hold for every word see that we've
got an equivalence in the vectors okay
so so now we have a tool to to measure
how how much similar are the words and
that's cosine distance mm-hmm so we
already know that similar words have
similar vector values and now we can use
the cosine distance to check to find the
most similar the most similar words yeah
and sorry about the square in them in
the on the edge I don't know appeared
but we want to find the most similar
words to blue and actually the the model
yeah finds those vectors here are from
from glove and implementation yeah it's
they're trained on Wikipedia and your
Geiger Ward five I think okay so we can
see that word to vac captures different
types of similarities even even if we
take some Renaissance painters actually
the most similar are other Renaissance
painters yeah it can generalize
Europe there is world and contender and
there are other forms of the word stance
ok it's pretty intelligent but we're not
so impressed yet right ok and who's ever
heard the King King - men plus women
equals Queen yeah ok that's cool so
that's what this is about our model is
capable of solving those analogy riddles
and we want to find the vector which is
the answer is the one which which has
has this value the highest so we're
looking for such file such V being that
this is the highest but what it actually
means is that it's we're looking for for
vector V B which has the maximum dot
product with v y and VX and but also at
the same time we're minimizing
minimizing the dot product with VA yep
so we actually now can it can do things
like tell us the capitals of the of the
tells us what country the capital is in
it can find us
the antonyms mm-hmm I think this one is
pretty nice that hope is to this
appointment as peace is to this
agreement and also on a little bit more
generalized level we can find that a
country is to language as Britain is to
English well that's that's myself it's
working
but I also a little disclaimer I picked
those
those examples so it doesn't work always
but I was able to find them right so I
was surprised by this one that it it
actually worked it was pretty nice mmm
but we can ask also it works effect for
the for its so called of opinions and
actually it thinks that only Matthias is
the Einstein of sign of painting and
also that Nietzsche is is the Copernicus
of philosophy so maybe in an alternate
world we would be sitting in in a niche
a philosophy center but ok so the
analogies are cool somewhere to Veck for
those models can solve them better than
an average american high schooler and
what more can we do mmm we can take take
award and measure its association with
measure whether its associated more with
with one one world or the other so for
example we can mmm we can measure we can
find the gender of a name we can we can
find find out if their words are
positive or negative and for that I
wanted to show you an interactive
visualization which I did under the
mentorship of the tomato who's sitting
here
so actually we can see that that the
male forms are much closer to he then
she and actually whoa that's that's cool
actually because we didn't tell the
mother the model the concept of gender
and now we can yep also it works with it
it's not so clear here but it works with
grammatical forms so we can see that the
adjectives aligned about around around
that v mm but what I also wanted to show
you are the jobs
okay so in the corpus which they worked
which this model was trained on they
were actually there were actually there
was actually some gender bias and so
okay so see oh it's like well it's much
closer to heat see that's surprising
isn't it yeah so we've got actor and
actress it's like it's actually aligned
aligned well mm and Bamber is that's
rather male the nannies rather female
yeah we don't like that but I will talk
about that in a minute and I wanted to
to invite you to play around play around
with that because I think that's that's
the most interesting part that you can
actually type in and see what's what's
gonna come up mm-hmm also the other
interesting thing is that I don't know
if if you heard of it but there is
something like conceptual metaphors
which are mmm
so so natural in our language that we
are not really aware of them and yeah
and we when we visualize the vectors
they kind of show up for example yep
conscious when we say something someone
is up there they were sleeping they're
conscious and actually that's it it has
a lot on D it is much more associated
with up then
it was similarly with rich and poor and
probably important and important I think
that's that's pretty nice that that it
shows here because it's something that
people are not not really aware of okay
so now imagine that you're a geologist
so you you like the earth and and rocks
and you've recently been interested in
data science someone told you about work
too vague and you just oh what's that
so we want to oh okay so I will order it
to find the world's most similar to rock
but as you can see that's a little bit
disappointing because people would
rather listen to music then talk about
Stone mmm
so what you do is you project the rock
factor on music vector and and subtract
it from from from the rock vector yes so
what it gives us is the vector that is
that vector of rock is perpendicular to
the second vector that's cool and it's
it actually gives us gives us good good
words which are associated with the
actual stone and rocks maybe maybe this
one isn't but it's a spin-off of the
Muppets it was called Fraggle Rock okay
so now you're a data scientist and and
you want to find the most similar words
to Python and suddenly yeah it's it's
Monty Python and Spamalot and John
Cleese so you take away
T and the O is actually working
yeah but you don't like that it's PHP
here so you'll take that away and and
you're left with with the animal mm-hmm
and that's that's a little bit sad for
you but you still continue on to be data
scientist also we've got our polish
language and the most the most similar
vector to it is literally nyan mm and
that that's cool that's okay let your
idea is near we take away a little onion
and whack because actually to the polish
things yeah so answer and Pope okay so
the next thing that we can do going back
to the gender bias is that we we can
take all of the vectors and reject the
gender for it so we reject the XI minus
key from all of the vectors so if on
normal vectors we would take giant also
the most similar are female names and
now when we take away the gender what we
get are the names of different genders
which are all which are well I guess
they are kind of the same maybe given in
the same time and similar if mother mmm
because the most the most similar
vectors to mother or daughter wife and
grandmother yeah and then there's
husband but actually mmm well actually
if you were asked for the most similar
thing the mother it should be father
right because the father is has has the
similar role and
if we take away the the gender what we
get is the closest one is father okay so
actually this gender bias in in the
world effect model can bring us some
problems because there are some studies
about developing and work to vac a
search engine which is which is helped
by the by words Tyvek which which
positions the the D search results based
on the association with with words and
that would be that would be kind of bad
probably for example for female
programmers because he is more
associated with programming than she and
that could bring the male programmers up
and the female programmer is down mmm so
I I read this study and there's a way to
get rid of that which is kind of
successful that they take the Amazon
third Amazon Cloud there's it's called
like that
mmm so they crowd source the anthologies
and people who write whether are there
are gender biased or not so like CEO
versus housewife it's it is gender
biased but for example sausage versus
bonds it's it's not gender biased
mmm so actually having data like this
you can you can make a transformation
might matrix which allows you to take
away their gender bias and the words are
then much less biased and it's kind of
it's a kind of a solution for this
problem
so vectors are generally of different
qualities there some analogies can be
found in in some in some models and some
not so the the most there are three most
important things that contribute to the
vector quality the most important well
corpus size it's typically a few billion
tokens the data that I used here was
trained on six billion tokens and they
were they were 5050 dimensions but they
were cut I had to cut down to the most
frequent words because my laptop wasn't
kind of coping mmm
so and also vector dimensions are very
important mmm for some tasks vector
dimensions like a thousand are better
but for some that is it's found that
smaller are better mmm and do you want
the one one explanation of this
phenomenon is that probably the less
dimensions makes the model find
different abstractions and relations
which allow it to incorporate the the
analogies better and also the vector
deriving algorithm that's that is also
very important but that's something
which is well that's a subject for
another talk and probably another 50
talks because there are not many and
many of them mmm yeah okay so that's all
from my side and thank you a lot you can
find me on on github you can find this
visualization and I'm invite you to play
around with it mmm yeah thanks that's
that's all from me
they still be having a question so so
many questions I have a question
regarding regarding this projection to
two dimensional space hmm so could you
explain like how did you make these
words projected to here shear good but
okay sure so we're talking about you're
talking about this right and and where
this comes from
okay so the first coordinate is the is
the dot product of let's say we want to
find the advice for for the word quiet
so the first coordinate is is the dot
product of the vector quiet and the
difference of good and bad and the
second coordinate is the dot product of
of the vector quiet and the difference
between down and up like it's like here
thanks for the presentation my question
is how much data transformation in terms
of limited ation and steaming is
required to use this approach and maybe
as extension Candice Candice library
methods methodology be used to boost or
replace current limit icers well
generally what I did here is I
downloaded the D vectors from from the
glove side which you all can do and I
just used them as they were so I didn't
have to do any any processing suit to
them and I'm not really really sure
about about what the quote what the
question is about that's probably my
fault but I guess I can find out and
contact you later did you do any hyper
parameter tuning I consider a vector
size or dimension the hyper parameter of
the award to vac and did you see any
changes in the results or or not well I
tried out a bigger data set vectors
trained on with many more dimensions and
the analogies were better better yeah in
that case yeah in that case I and I also
checked out different publications which
were comparing different architectures
and the size of the corpus and decide
the length of the vectors and generally
the bigger is better right okay and the
corpus was downloaded from what were in
the description on the PI data side
there's a link but it was generally it
was downloaded from
yeah that's from here we can you can
download different versions here yeah I
took this one and for the visualization
here it has to work locally because it's
written in JavaScript so actually it's
the 100,000th most frequent words and
the the numbers in the vectors are cut
down to three places after the comma
because it had to be small enough so
people could go go there and download it
so here are not not the best vectors but
the best I could do did you try to could
you go to the example when you were
subtracting they're like music aspects
of Asher rock I mean the code yeah right
so did you try to subtract like more
than the music because what what what
are you doing is like subtracting the
aspect of music so like projecting on an
or top on orthogonal complement of the
music so you could like did you try to
find this subspace that corresponds to
music or did you just do this this one I
mean for music the subspace
corresponding to music should contain
like classical piano or something like
this yeah yeah I get what you mean
that's I probably could have subtracted
music and piano and powerful for example
but actually if you subtract too much it
it gets there they just
you get some trash from the yeah
probably if if I try to to subtract
piano etc it might have been better but
I didn't try it
yep yeah probably you could do that but
I didn't try it out yeah I can I can
publish the notebooks online if you
wanted to try it out yeah so we you mean
yep we'll for tuvok it's kind of well if
you have polish is a fractional language
so if we don't have rock in Polish it's
cava but it's also scoured scholars car
bomb so you you've got different endings
and work to back isn't as effective for
reflectional languages so it wouldn't be
quite impressive yeah but there is
research going on regarding taking the
the anagram parts of of words and then
applying it to to the vector generate
generation mmm but I don't know how is
good how it's doing for Polish because
they did it for English in the
publication and I think that's that's
not nice last questions
I was just wondering would words effect
be useful for creating a sentiment
analysis tool like Twitter well
you could probably find fine well it
what would you recommend sorry if not
what would you recommend instead for
creating sentiment analysis yes well I
think that for creating sentiment
analysis work to like wouldn't be so so
useful because because forward to Veck
it is also important what parts of the
sentence are the words so good and it's
also not good with telling apart
antonyms yeah your slides I've got yeah
I didn't put it here but you can see
that if we take if you want to find we
good it's too bad as up this to hmm the
second the second thing is up because
actually antonyms also find themselves
in the in the similar context so we can
probably say that the food in the
restaurant is cheap but you could also
say in the similar context that the food
in the restaurant is is expensive so
that's I don't think that it would have
very good application here
thank you okay so if anyone has another
question so I think you can find Julie
on the coffee break yeah
[Applause]